are we seeing the return of the 90s
action genre I really hope so and before
we talk about that gonna give some love
to the sponsor of this video this video
is brought to you by Dr Squatch Squatch
is changing the way folks approach
hygiene their product leaves you looking
great smelling great Ergo you feel great
all without any of the harsh chemicals
you find in some other brands and squash
is no stranger to this Channel and
that's because I use their product daily
and I have for years they have shampoo
conditioner deodorant soap all in the
pine tar scent because well it is my
favorite they even have hand lotion yes
also in pine tar for me leave your mark
with every hinge or anything else you
might want to do with hand lotion
scented as pine tar
anywho so click the link below and use
promo code dsq Johns and new users can
get 20 off of your purchase of 20 or
more and now we talk about the plan
before the trains in the automobile not
really relevant for this review but I
can't help but think of that when I see
the poster or the title of this movie
[Music]
three stars Gerard Butler is this
airline pilot Mike Coulter of Luke Cage
Fame has a criminal being transported on
this airliner then the plane goes down
on an island that's run by militia and
now the captain and the inmate on his
flight have to team up to get out of
this sticky situation need to save some
passengers and Gerard Butler he was
great in this movie but he's also great
doing this
total 90s action throwback film been 10
years at this point but Olympus Has
Fallen yeah that's what he did there and
he was great in there too Gerard
Butler's just good at these 90s action
Throwbacks and I really do mean that I
know I've said that a few times already
in this review but that's that's what
this movie is no there are movies coming
out now and they've been delayed for
about two and a half years or so this is
a movie that feels like it was delayed
by about two and a half decades or so
but I mean that in a good way it sounds
like an insult but it's not it was
either delayed by two and a half decades
or someone just found the script blew
the dust off and they were like oh yeah
this well let's make that now let's not
change it at all there are two points
here they sound like conflicting
information but both are correct I
totally get why this movie was put in
January in 2023 however if this movie
had come out in the 90s this would have
been a summer release easy Arnold would
be the pilot you know the cast this is
your captain speaking hold on to your
ass
Arnold Schwarzenegger Wesley Snipes
plain coming summer in 1997. and what I
like is everyone really has their role
you know Gerard Butler's The Good Pilot
like he's just a good dude he's the guy
you want to be the pilot on the next
flight you're on there was a bit of
turbulence actually not a bit it's
pretty intense turbulence he comes out
of the captain's cabin like is everyone
okay ma'am oh no you dropped that baby's
bottle there you go is everyone all
right I've been on some flights with
some pretty intense turbulence Captain
just acts like homelander oh that was a
big one but Gerard Butler is badass when
it comes to hand-to-hand combat Firearms
but he's not the MVP badass that is Mike
coulter's character but it's it's
balanced and allocated in a way that
character should be you got Gerard
Butler he's the captain he's the leader
of the group
did you think what I just thought
transformed from the norm by the nuclear
group was that the right I did I thought
that he's there to keep everyone feeling
secure feeling safe he's a good leader
Mike coulter's character is the total
covert Ops guy finding his Redemption
through this situation then you even got
another dude who's trying to fix the
electronics on the plane you know like
everyone has their role in this movie
it's not like another Ninja Turtle
reference coming at you it's not like
the NES Ninja Turtles game where it's
just Donatello and his three meat
Shields and no one else matters I'll say
the passengers don't have their role as
much they're just there to be scared
they're there to be hostages which makes
sense when they were bored in the plane
in the movie I was like 18 passengers
that is the lightest flight I've ever
heard of or been on but you can't have a
movie like this with 200 passengers and
have any of the passengers stand out
just doesn't work not for a two-hour
film anyway however in those movies
their 80s and 90s action movies this
movie's clearly throwing back to those
movies that had memorable villains not
this one the militia coming after them
very scary very real threat when you're
watching the film that stands out as an
entity but there is a guy who runs this
militia and this dude is just he's the
Baddie he's just bad guy you got your
Alpha bad guy and your beta bad guy and
then the militia that follow them and
that's that don't look for Hans Gruber
or Cyrus the virus in this movie that's
not the vibe there's no villain that
stands out so I got a point in cinema
making memorable villain just stopped
being a priority it was like all right I
guess we don't have to do that always
nice when it happens but I consider it a
surprise when a villain does stand out
this is not one of the surprises just
kind of goes down how you think it will
and there were a couple of moments where
I was like well that just got fast
tracked it was like all right this is
really
oh okay that's over but in the end plane
I want to say it's what you would think
an action movie in January in 2023 would
be but I feel like that's cutting it
short it's not inaccurate it's not like
this movie's trying to be Macbeth or
anything but it leans into its cheese
and its premise enough to give you some
of that flavor of 80s action movie and
90s action movie some of the flavor
that's been gone for too long maybe we
want a little bit of it back it
scratches an itch that modern Cinema
doesn't generally try to do it's very
Niche thing it's a sub-genre among the
modern action movie genre it's one
that's very self-aware if you like 90s
action movie Throwbacks I want to check
this one out I had myself a good time no
alcohol required I also want to mention
the NES Ninja Turtles game to give you a
PTSD flashbacks swimming in the water
looking for those [ __ ] bombs with
barely enough time to do it seaweed's
all shocking the [ __ ] out of you I'm
just saying any anxiety people folks
from my generation have now I'm pretty
convinced it started with that game and
that level all right so plane have you
seen it what did you think about it your
favorite 90s action movie throwback
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]